today's question comes from Matt in
Tennessee we're debt-free and we're
trying to buy a house the problem is we
have poor credit the mortgage company
suggested we get a prepaid credit card
not a regular credit card since they do
report to FICO I know you don't like
credit cards or credit scores but would
a prepaid be a viable option
no would not get a prepaid credit card
if you have a poor credit score there is
one of two things going on one is you
have some bad debt outstanding that you
need to go and make right you need to
settle with them and get that account
closed or two you have paid existing
accounts that are not yet paid off too
slowly so you would want to get those
paid off because we tell you not to buy
a home until your debt free now if
you've paid off everything except your
home and you have no debt except your
home and it was paid late and that is
holding your credit score down that's
the third possibility then you would
just pay your home on time for a few
more months and you'll see your credit
score improve but we're not going to go
out there and start playing with debt
products to quote build our credit
I'm never going to recommend you build
your credit and you do things to build
your credit if you have existing credit
that is very very high and you have a
high credit score what that means is you
paid a lot of interest and you've been
playing kissy-face with the bank a lot
if you have that you use that to get
your mortgage if you don't then you get
all your accounts closed and when you
have zero accounts open open not even
open they're closed they're paid off and
they're closed if you have zero accounts
open in six to nine to 12 months
somewhere in there your credit score
will completely disappear and you'll
have no credit score but screwing around
with a prepaid credit card is going to
keep this thing it's going to keep
bumping along and you're going to keep
you know struggling here
and so if you're sitting there with a
5:30 or a 600 or a 550 or something like
that that usually means you have bad
debt outstanding or you've still got
debt outstanding that you've not paid
off
and it was slow so get it all paid off
and close all the accounts that's your
best option to move to a zero score
rather than trying to build back up your
credit